"
♪ ♪
THE WHITE HOUSE STIRRING UP
OUTRAGE OVER THE SUPPLY CHAIN
CRISIS.
SOME CEOs SAY PRISON BITE AND
WAITED ALSO SO LONG TO FIX THE
NATION'S BROKEN SYSTEM, AND
CHRISTMAS IS COMING SOON.
THE PRESIDENT'S CHIEF OF STAFF
SPARKING BACKLASH AFTER CLAIMING
THAT TOUCHED MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS HAVE LIFE CONCERNS,
REFERRING TO THEM AS "HIGH-CLASS
PROBLEMS."
"MOST OF THE CANONIC PROBLEMS WE
ARE FACING OUR HIGH-CLASS
PROBLEM.
WE WOULD NOT HAVE THEM IF THE ON
A PLANE AT RIGHT WAS STILL 10%.
WE WOULD HAVE A WORSE PROBLEM."
FINE, BUT THE WHITE HOUSE
SPENDING THAT THE TWEET DECK
THIS.
>> WOULD YOU AGREE THAT THAT IS
A LITTLE BIT --
>> Secretary Psaki: DO YOU
THINK TO GO TWEETS MEANS MORE?
THE ON EMPLOYMENT RATE HAS COME
DOWN AND BEEN CUT IN HALF,
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE BUYING MORE
GOODS, TRAVELING, AND BECAUSE
DEMAND IS UP, AND BECAUSE THE
ECONOMY IS TURNING BACK UP.
THE CHIEF OF STAFF'S TWITTER
HABITS, IT'S NOT A PRIORITY.
I WILL TELL YOU, THE CHIEF OF
STAFF IS SPEAKING ON HIS OWN
ACCORD TO MATTERS OF CONGRESS,
TO THE MEDIA, FREQUENTLY, AS ANY
CHIEF OF STAFF DOES.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
ANYONE HERE TO BE ABLE TO TOUT
POINTS THAT THEY FIND
INTERESTING.
>> Dana: ALL THIS IS
AMERICA -- A SPIKE IN THEIR GAS
BILLS.
WE WILL LOOK AT THIS, FORECAST
ATOMIC FORECASTS FOR FUEL
INCREASES IN LIGHTS.
THE COST OF OIL WAS SHOOTING UP
LIKE A ROCKET.
I HAVE SO MANY THOUGHTS, SO MANY
THOUGHTS.
REMEMBER, JESSE, RETWEET DOES
NOT EQUAL ENDORSEMENT?
HOWEVER, HE'S NOT TWEETING IN
HIS PERSONAL CAPACITY.
HE IS ALWAYS TWEETING AND
RE-TWEETING LIKE A TEENAGE GIRL,
RE-TWEETING AND RETWEETING ALL
THESE THINGS.
HE DIDN'T JUST RETWEET IT.
HE SAID THAT'S COME IN ALL CAPS
COME UP WITH TWO ARROWS DOWN
SAYING "THIS IS WHAT THEY
THINK."
THIS IS LIKE THEIR "DEPLORABLE"
MOMENTS.
>> Jesse: LIKE A TEENAGE GIRL,
DANA.
REALLY?
[LAUGHTER]
YOU ARE BETTER THAN THAT.
I APOLOGIZE TO THE AUDIENCE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dana: TEENAGE GIRLS ARE NOT
ON TWITTER.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: APOLOGIZE ON TIKTOK.
NOT A GREAT CHIEF OF STAFF,
THAT'S CLEAR.
JEN PSAKI BOMBED TODAY.
ALL SHE HAD TO SAY WAS "WE ARE
ON IT.
WE WILL DO WHATEVER WE CAN TO
RELEASE PRESSURE ON THIS
CRISIS."
IT'S A BAD ANSWER TO PEOPLE THAT
ARE GETTING HAMMERED.
THEY HAVE BEEN ALL OVER THE MAP,
TRYING TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
FIRST, THEY SAID THERE'S NO
INFLATION.
THEN, THEY SAID IT IS
TRANSITORY, AND NOW, THEY ARE
SAYING "IT'S A SIGN OF
PROGRESS."
IT'S NOT GOING TO CUT IT.
IT DOES NOT AFFECT WEALTHY
PEOPLE THAT BARELY AT ALL.
YOU CAN'T FLY, BUY, HIGHER.
LIFE HAS NOT BEEN MADE EASIER BY
JOE BIDEN'S PRESIDENCY.
THIS IS WHERE WE ARE NOW.
I HAVE WATCHED THE WHOLE PRESS
BRIEFING, BECAUSE I WANTED TO
SEE HOW SHE WOULD ANSWER.
THE MEDIA IS ON THE SIDE OF THE
DEMOCRATS, BUT THEY ARE NOT
DOING THE DEMOCRATS ANY FAVORS
WHEN HALF OF THEIR QUESTIONS ARE
ABOUT TRUMP.
HALF OF THEIR QUESTIONS ARE
ABOUT THE JANUARY 6TH SUBPOENA
BATTLE.
YOU TALK TO PEOPLE ON THE
STREETS, NO ONE KNOWS WHAT THAT
IS, NO ONE CARES.
HALF THE PEOPLE DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE WORD SUBPOENA IS.
IF THEY THINK THE COUNTRY CARES
ABOUT THAT, THEY ARE NOT
INFORMED ABOUT WHAT THE COUNTRY
CARES ABOUT.
SOMETIMES FOX ASKS ABOUT THE
BORDER, SUPPLY CHAINS,
INFLATION, CRIME, THAT'S IT, BUT
THEY ARE NOT BEING WELL SERVED
BY THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA WHO
MAKES EVERYTHING ABOUT TRUMP.
LET'S SAY HE GETS A WIN, A
SMALLER WIN ON SOME OF THESE
SPENDING DEALS.
YOU STILL ARE NOT GOING TO FEEL
THE IMPACTS OF THAT FOR YEARS.
YOU KNOW HOW LONG IT TAKES TO
BUILD A PLUG-IN FOR AN ELECTRIC
CAR, HOW LONG IT TAKES TO GET A
NEW GOVERNMENT PROGRAM OFF THE
GROUND?
ALL YOU ARE GOING TO SEE
IMMEDIATELY OUR TAX HIKES.
THIS COMING WINTER, YOU COULD
SEE MORE COVID IN THE
UNITED STATES.
YOU COULD SEE HIGH HOME HEATING
BILLS, MORE FUEL PRICES THROUGH
THE ROOF.
IT'S GOING TO BE TOUGH.
>> OIL WILL BE UP TO 53%.
THAT'S WHAT THE GOVERNMENT SAID.
>> Jesse: THAT'S A SIGN OF
PROSPERITY.
>> Greg: IF YOU KEEP THE
TEMPERATURE DOWN, IT'S GOOD FOR
METABOLISM.
WHAT IS A LOW CLASS PROBLEM?
THIS IS A HIGH-CLASS PROBLEM.
IT IS A LOW CLASS PROBLEM UNDER
BIDEN, COCAINE AND?
I REALIZE THAT A HIGH-CLASS
PROBLEM IS SOMETHING THAT ONLY
THE HIGH CLASSES CAN WEATHER.
THIS IS EXACTLY THE SAME TACTIC
BEING DEALT WITH CRIME AND
IMMIGRATION.
IT DOES NOT AFFECT US,
THEREFORE, IT DOES NOT EXIST.
THERE WILL BE NO SHORTAGES OF
TOYS FOR PELOSI'S GRANDKIDS.
THEY ARE FINE.
THAT'S WHY THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT
THIS!
I ALSO LOVE HOW JOE BIDEN IS
ASKING THE OIL INDUSTRY FOR
HELP.
THIS IS THE INDUSTRY HE HURT
JUST AS HE GOT INTO OFFICE.
HE COULD REVERSE ALL THE ACTIONS
HE TOOK AGAINST THEM, RATHER
THAN ASKING FOR HELP.
HE IS LIKE A GUY THAT ASKS TO GO
TO YOUR HOUSE AFTER HE BURNED IT
DOWN.
IT'S A LEGITIMATE QUESTION,
GIVEN HIS FACULTIES.
MAYBE, HE DOES NOT REMEMBER THAT
HE KILLED THE PIPELINE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: THE OLD AGE
STRATEGY.
>> Greg: MAYBE HE FORGOT.
HE MIGHT HAVE FORGOTTEN THAT HE
DEMONIZED -- I'M TRYING TO BE
HELPFUL HERE THAT MAYBE IT'S NOT
HIS FAULT, BUT NOW HE IS SAYING
TO THE PEOPLE HE SCREWED OVER "I
COULD USE A HAND HERE.
YOU GUYS HAVE HAD TO PICK UP THE
SLACK BECAUSE I SCREWED UP.
>> HERE IS A CEO RESPONDED,
SUGGESTING THAT THE PRIVATE
SECTOR NEEDS TO STEP UP.
>> WITH ALL THE RESPECT TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN, BUT HE JUST
ORDERED IS TOO LITTLE ALSO WAS A
LATE PERIOD IS ONLY 72 DAYS
LEFT.
WHETHER THE PORTS ARE OPEN
24 HOURS A DAY OR 48 HOURS A
DAY, YOU CANNOT GET LABOR.
IF YOU CANNOT GET LABOR, YOU
CANNOT GET TRUCKS, YOU CANNOT
GET THE MERCHANDISE OUT.
EVEN IF YOU GET THEM OUT, IT'S
GOING TO BE ALSO SILLY FOR
CHRISTMAS.
>> Dana: GERALDO, THE PRIVATE
SECTOR SAYING "WE WANT TO SELL
MY PRODUCT.
THE PROBLEM IS THERE ARE THESE
BOTTLENECKS WITH NOT ENOUGH
TRUCK DRIVERS."
>> Geraldo: THAT'S WHY WE NEED
MORE YOUNG TRUCK DRIVERS
WORKING, AS WELL.
THE PROBLEM WITH WHAT KLAIN
RETWEETED IS IT HAS A MARIE
ANTOINETTE VIBE.
IT IS A "LET THEM EAT CAKE"
VIBE.
IT IS "THOSE LOWER CLASSES THAT
HAVE GOT THEIR ISSUES, AND WE
UPPER -- THAT'S WHY
AND WE UPPER --"THAT'S WHY I ALE
UPPER ELITE ECHELON
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THE REASON IT'S ALL HAPPENING IS
COVID IS STILL THE ATMOSPHERE.
IT'S BOMBING EVERYBODY OUT,
SEPARATING EVERYBODY.
BEST OF ALL PLAYERS, BLACK
PEOPLE, THE COPS.
YOU HAVE COVID, AND THEN YOU
HAVE THE RESIDUAL LINGERING
WOUND FROM AFGHANISTAN.
WE NEVER GOT OVER IT.
THAT IS WHAT PIERCED THE SHIELD
OF JOE BIDEN.
ONCE HE WAS SHOWN TO BE
VULNERABLE THERE -- I REMEMBER
SITTING HERE AND SURPRISING
MYSELF BY MY CRITICISM OF
PRESIDENT BIDEN, THE ECONOMIC OF
ACTUATION, AND AS I WAS
SPEAKING -- I LIKE HIM.
IF I'M NAILING HIM, IT'S A
TRICKLE-DOWN EFFECT.
I REALLY THINK IT'S BAD, BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER THINGS
THAT ARE WORSE.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
HAPPENED, THERE ARE THESE GUYS,
IT'S CALLED LIBERAL PATRIOTS.
THEY ARE CONSERVATIVES, YOU CAN
CHECK THIS OUT.
JUST THIS MORNING, BEFORE ALL OF
THIS HAPPENED, THEY HAD A PIECE
THAT SAID "THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
HAS A HUGE PROBLEM.
THEY ARE NOT DOING ANYTHING TO
WIN BACK THE WORKING CLASS, AND
THEN TWEET LIKE THIS --" I HAD
TO IMAGINE THAT EVEN THOUGH SHE
HAD TO DEFEND IT, IF SHE COULD
TAKE TWITTER AWAY FROM
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS, SHE
PROBABLY WOULD.
>> Katie: AS DANE ALWAYS SAYS,
YOU DO NOT HAVE TO TWEET
EVERYTHING.
[LAUGHTER]
IT'S BETTER TO SAY LESS THAN
MORE.
>> Dana: DON'T TWEET!
>> Katie: THIS IS AN
ADMINISTRATION, THAT SINCE THE
BEGINNING, HAS HAD A PATTERN.
THEY TAKE A POLICY POSITION THAT
INVOLVES ATTACKING AND INDUSTRY.
THEY ATTACKED OIL AND GAS, THEY
THROWN A VACCINE MANDATE TO
DISTRACT FROM AFGHANISTAN
WITHOUT ISSUING A RULE.
THEN, THEY PUMPED THE ECONOMY
FULL OF THIS MONEY SO EMPLOYERS
HAVE TO COMPETE WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, SO THERE ARE NOT
ENOUGH WORKERS.
WHEN THINGS DON'T WORK OUT AND
THERE IS A CRISIS, YOU CHANGE
THE POLICY OR PIVOT, THEY
ATTACKED THE INDUSTRY AND SAY
"YOU HAVE TO BAIL US OUT, FIX
THIS."
IT'S ONE THING FOR CHRISTMAS
PRESENTS NOT TO GET DELIVERED ON
TIME.
DO WE CALL JOE BIDEN SCROOGE OR
THE GRINCH YET?
IT'S ANOTHER THING WHEN BASIC
GOODS CANNOT GET DELIVERED ON
TIME.
THIS ADMINISTRATION TENDS TO
BURY ITS HEAD AND SAY "THERE'S
NOTHING HAPPENING THOUGH MIGHT
HAPPEN, THIS WAS IN OPERABLE."
THERE WILL BE CIVIL UNREST IF
THEY DO NOT PREPARE THINGS TO
GET DELIVERED BY A MILK,
DIAPERS.
>> Greg: FREE KICK!
WHAT ABOUT FRUITCAKE?
SPEEFOUR WHAT WOULD WE DO
WITHOUT DIAPERS?
>> Jesse: PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
BE FIGHTING OVER TELEVISION.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: THEY FIGHT EVERY
YEAR.